en rueda de prensa desde el Ministerio
de relaciones exteriores de ciudad de
Guatemala y A muy temprana hora de este
martes el canciller Mario bucaro
confirmó que de los 40 fallecidos en la
tragedia de Ciudad Juárez 28 son de
Guatemala en su totalidad hombres la
rapidez con que se supo que la mayoría
de los muertos provienen de este país
centroamericano se explica porque muy
recientemente un equipo de trabajadores
consulares los había visitado y
entrevistado en dicha estación
migratoria donde se encontraban
retenidos en ese sentido el canciller
bucaro corroboró que las identidades de
estos guatemaltecos pertenecen a tres
distintos departamentos del noroeste de
Guatemala que colinda con el sur de
México Huehuetenango San Marcos y
Quetzaltenango de manera que activó un
protocolo de emergencia para encontrar
las familias y repatriar los cuerpos lo
más pronto posible como un segundo punto
ordenó la apertura de una investigación
que acompañará a la del lado mexicano y
según él y aquí abro
llas averiguar lo que sucedió dar con
los responsables Buscar juicio castigo y
reparación Pero dentro de su alocución
no dejó de responsabilizar culpar de
esta tragedia a los coyotes o polleros
como se les conoce a los traficantes de
personas que por un promedio de 10 mil
dólares llevan a miles de guatemaltecos
desde Centroamérica hacia Estados Unidos
para cumplirles un sueño económico